yoyo
les femmes sont folles de moix de
mont-joli thorax de mes morceaux de
choix le mec me soulage axa j'en ai rien
à carrer de ces femelles ronde de ses
maîtresses ce cumul des bruits et puis
les blondes moi je préfère les rousses 2
80 à 3 ans qu'on trouve dans la brousse
encore la gueule
la tarte tatin
elles sont folles de mon sexe jusque
dans le sussex et c'est loin raffolent
de mon index de matrot de latex
collectionne les braguettes mello
j'arrête ce trail comme d'être devant
mais qu'est la tulette mais moi je
préfère les routes de 83 ans contre
seulement
la ballon
de 83 ans
dans la ruhr
j'ai eu comme maîtresse la femme dort en
point la fille de rambo 2 la mère de
rambo ils attendent d'euros qui vont
très sur le tapis aujourd'hui c'est fini
j'espère julie image mais les housses de
3%
4 3 dans tous les bons coups sur la
gueule
l'acteur
dulon
le lot
de 4,3 en contre sedan larusso temps
sans rien que la
je vais faire les routes de 4-3 aux
trousses dans la grosse offre un sommet